e
à l'époque où
tout neuf il ya ma vigne
ja ja matin s'ouvre à moi et m'a fait
pauvre
et tout faux toutoune et alors et alors
ça y est c'est fait dans l'eau on est
bien là 1 allez tout ne dit à ma belle
alors et alors jalouser secondes de vol
voilà le tout fou ses chorus un tout fou
c'est vrai ya kiki c'est le petit
dernier
et puis les 2 et de bergers allemands
voilà tout ou non tout ou gras qui a 11
ans et vad
alors moi j'ai un petit un petit
penchant je veux dire pour pour toundra
qui la paye demoiselle toundra n'a
jamais voulu de n'ai jamais voulu être
marié on a eu beaucoup de problèmes
j'aurais bien aimé qu'elle nous fasse
des petits
elle a 11 ans maintenant alors bon lait
est le vide complètement avec nous dans
la maison et il faut la soigner
maintenant parce qu'elle est là quelques
problèmes vada leur vendent c'est le
sait la grosse bête c'est le gardien de
la maison c'est aussi le le chien
méchamment maryse va dire comme j'en ai
jamais eu et en étant enfin je rentre
c'est très important ça alors j'avais
peur j'avais peur des chiens avaient
peur des chats
les pigeons vous allez voir qu'ils sont
beaux
bonjour aller
alors mon chat voilà le chat room à tous
il a quel âge il a il a un an
il s'appelle qui s'appelle chat tout
simplement un chat un chat
on dit souvent que les les chiens les
chats ne s'entendent pas et là il ya
aucun problème vraiment le chat souvent
dort dans l'est dans les pattes de tom
brady berger allemand
et puis jouent ensemble ils montent sur
le dos à mu saute se passe bien
tu vas nous montre un petit peu 1 il
nous il est bien là le chat un regarde
tous nous aller tombera elle est déjà un
petit peu on va voir un petit peu sage 1
min
pour
jean non ça c'est hippolyte hippolyte il
ya casimir aussi le roma qui les a
baptisés comme ça ce sont de poney
connemara
c'est là la grande passion de romain ça
de mon fils les chevaux ils ont quel âge
ils ont quatre ans tous les deux et ça a
été la grande surprise il y a deux ans
au petit papa noël les animaux la
campagne la famille enfin tout ça ça
fait un tout finalement
et lorsque j'arrive lorsque j'arrive
chez moi c'est vraiment autre chose et
c'est un besoin pour moi je veux dire ça
fait c'est important comme comme la
famille est importante comme la maison
est important et c'est là que je reprend
des forces
je sais pas on oublie tout quand on est
à cheval je ne sais pas comment je monte
je n'ai jamais appris à monter je veux
dire mais ça se voit sûrement mais je
peux je prends du plaisir à sympa c'est
extra et puis on pense à rien quand on
est sur le sur l'animal je pense à bien
tu n'iras pas tomber et puis elle plie à
me promener je peux dire ce sont mes
enfants qui m'ont appris à mieux
connaître les animaux c'est certain
pourquoi parce que parce que tous les
enfants tous les enfants aiment les
animaux et quand on a la possibilité et
la pl après la place et surtout de d'en
avoir bon bah c'est il faut leur offrir
ça
et c'est sûrement très important que
j'ai aussi le grandir avec les aliments
et de s'en occuper de leur apprendre
preto
oh